so when does Bezos come into the picture
and say because that was really out of
left field people are like okay Amazon's
dabbling with this Amazon Prime video
maybe they're gonna do some original
programming whatever but then they buy
Justin they buy twitch and we're like
what was that about yeah so what
happened how does that go down
we ended up spinning out Socialcam that
one has its own company when she's a
couple years later sold it to Autodesk
they went for sixty million dollars and
protectable yeah not not bad and then we
ended up you know kept working on twitch
over the years m8 became the CEO is if
he was really the product visionary
behind twitch in the driving force and
then after you know maybe four years of
operation and basically the first six
months at which we set these milestones
and it just kind of grew every month it
grew and grew and grew and then
eventually you know basically anything
that gets big enough in Silicon Valley
there's kind of interest from all the
fan companies they want they're
interested in it and Amazon was was
interested and I think they saw the
value in the business it's something
where there's you know they're it's kind
of like it was just turning the corner
at the point of being kind of like
Netflix know like Netflix have first
started off you want to see certain
videos so you know is it on Netflix and
now you go to Netflix to find something
to watch right right and I think twitch
had just was going through that
transition in 2014 where at first I was
you started to go I want to see this
certain type of video or this certain
broadcaster or the sort of content
creator and then to now like oh it
twitches a brand when I associate with
certain kind of entertainment so I'm
gonna go there and watch and so I think
twitch had they saw this like longevity
in it and you know and so that was in
2014
September 2014 that's the best day of
your life ah / - that point I think the
day of the day of my life that that had
happened I remember at this time
Emmitt was running the company I'm on
just on the board of directors on
non-operational in the company again so
I went to Burning Man yeah and the deal
was supposed to close and I'm like they
had my signatures in escrow or whatever
so I don't have to do anything so I'm
like you're on the playa I'm gonna
Burning Man and it rains at Burning Man
and I woke up in a pool of water cuz I
was sleeping in a little yurt that we
made out of like construction foam and
so I woke up that pre you having money
so you didn't have the ability
and also you know you gotta go I wanted
to go in a way that was more authentic
got it I like that part of it of it so I
woke up didn't rain that night and we
didn't tape duct tape or the tarp on ER
into the sides of this conform in mud so
I I woke up in playa mud and I fell
later on I end of mine comes in there's
no cell phone service and in friend of
mine comes in and he's like
congratulations so I knew was on Wow
yeah that's amazing yeah that was your
best burn then that was it was it was
yeah did you go to the temple and put a
justin TV logo and r.i.p rest in peace
justin TV it is such an amazing like
almost decade journey of like eight
years of crazy ride you know and five
years of it six years to where was just
dismal you know we had fun times i
learned a lot right that's the most
important thing is i you know i was
working with my friends my very good
friends I learned a lot a lot of like I
started from very bad at many things I
was tweeting about this last week but I
started with so few skills right like no
programming's barely any programming
skills horrible management and
leadership skills and didn't really
understand anything about business as
evidence by the fact that we try to
start a company about me broadcasting
from my camera on my head yeah and I
learned so much through this process
that even the dismal kind of sad times
were very productive at the end of it
you know I look back fondly on them yeah
it is the interesting thing about
startups especially in that era because
in the 2003 to 2008 era people don't
remember but the dot-com era had crushed
everybody souls you were in probably
high school or college or high school in
college it yeah so you were watching
that and I was like I'll never always
want to participate but I'm too I didn't
know I'm young I don't know anything
right ever I was like it's over I'll
never get my other yeah that window has
shot exactly the window for young people
to make money a shot I remember people
saying that the end of the dot-com boom
young people will never make money
never again nobody will trust young
people with hordes of capital to go
change the world and anybody who is
building something between 2003 and 2008
I'd say between 2003 and 2007 by default
it was interesting because they weren't
doing it to make money it was no money
there's a web log sync will be built in
gadget or movable type or Digg or
delicious or Flickr these were all
passion projects by small teams I just
wanted to see those products exist
that's what I loved about Silicon Valley
in San Francisco and during that time
because people were just doing it not
because they wanted to make money
because it was not a popular thing to do
and was not a good career path they were
doing it because they thought it'd be
cool it was like a cool experiment yeah
yeah let's see if we can actually get
this website to exist in the world yeah
and like will people do it or interact
with each other on this website
well people Digg or reddit this story
yeah where people understand what that
even means exactly and I love that I
love that sense of exploration and I
feel like I know this is gonna sound
like the jaded like sad guy an old guy
but like I feel like there's a little
bit of that that's missing now here in
San Francisco because there's a lot of
the cultures change is matured and
people are coming here for their career
now you know they're like okay I want
yeah like vehicle is a good career move
you know you know what's interesting
about that is I think it's cyclical
because that actually happened in the
dot-com era yeah like towards the end of
it people are like okay I'm graduating I
went to Harvard got my MBA and I'm gonna
go into comm yeah pesco that's a good
move and and everybody flowed into
pets.com and every possible iteration
and the second it got hard when the.com
boom they ran back to Goldman Sachs they
ran back to Madison Avenue to get an ad
job and it story I call a tourist season
like we're in a middle of tourist season
right now it's high season yeah and
there's a lot of people here like who
are building companies I don't know if
their hearts really in it yeah a lot of
me to stuff are when we get back let's
talk about your new company atrium and
how you raised what 90 million for this
seventy five million only seventy five
poultry said a paltry seventy five
you're going big you've got over a
hundred people working at atrium o'clock
its atrium koay teow I um CO and I want
to hear why you decided to try to
disrupt reinvent the legal system when
we get back on this week in startups
[Music]